and welcome to Hann tonight we begin
with a Fox News Alert the Epstein files
they have been released and we are now
learning the names of more than 150
individuals allegedly associated with
the powerful convicted pedophile that
includes former President Bill Clinton
now coming up we'll get reaction tonight
from Pam Bondi Mark gagos will join us
and Alan dtz who once represented
Epstein in court and whose name appears
on the list he will join us also tonight
shocking new video from Nevada where a
convicted criminal this is unbelievable
brutally attacking that judge after she
sentenced him to jail and it goes on
from there we have a lot more coming up
and later I do have bad news for John
Stewart formerly of The Daily Show uh
who once begged me along with the Jersey
Boys at Nathan Lane to stay in New York
you might remember take a look Sean we
know you're mad at us and you have every
right to be Occupy Wall Street Governor
Cuomo that weird smell New York has made
a lot of big mistakes but we're going to
change just please
stay and they actually sing anyway now
that I have officially moved uh to the
free state of Florida my new permanent
residents uh I don't know will John
Stewart the Jersey Boys Nathan Lane ever
survive Jimmy fail is here tonight to
respond but first we turn back to our
top story the ultra wealthy convicted
pedophile Jeffrey Epstein we know is
dead but he leaves behind what is a long
trip of high-profile Associates and
friends including many who knew about or
may have participated in his massive web
of sexual abuse to date no one other
than Epstein and his partner uh galain
Maxwell have ever been charged or
convicted in connection with their quote
underage sex trafficking ring and
allegations but tonight a court has just
unsealed a list of names in a civil suit
this one brought by one of Epstein's
alleged victims now before we get to the
names and the allegations here is a
quick reminder for decades je Jeffrey
Epstein was shrouded in mystery he was
once regarded as a billionaire investor
no one seemed to know how Epstein became
so wealthy and so well connected he
owned multiple private planes a fleet of
cars several massive Estates all across
the country including what was the
largest home right there in New York
City Epstein even had his very own
private island named quote little St
James now today many of you know it as
quote pedophile Island based on numerous
allegations that young girls were
trafficked to Epstein's Island and that
they were in fact abused they were also
abused allegations according to many at
his Palm Beach Mansion his new his home
in New York his sprawling ranch in New
Mexico and his luxury apartment in Paris
in France at the very same time Epstein
hung out with some of the most
well-connected people on Earth including
billionaires actors world leaders and
according to flight logs former
President Bill Clinton took nearly two
dozen flights on Epstein's private
planes including the jet that came to be
known as the Lolita Express and
tonight's unsealed documents do mention
the former president including this
exchange with one of Epstein's victims
quote Epstein said that one time Clinton
liked them young referring to girls now
keep in mind these are allegations it's
from a civil suit and that was a suit
that was settled and have not been
proven in a court of law former
President Clinton has denied any
wrongdoing now of course Clinton is not
the only high profile name released
tonight hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else